à l'effort bidabé un peu trop de monde
on est trop bousculés si le marché ne
punit un tel succès avec ses 130
commerçants c'est pour une raison tout
ça c'est sûr les agriculteurs c'est des
petites structures
c'est pas forcément du bio mais il ya
vraiment que la qualité
moi je vais chercher mes fromages ici
les champignons chez johnny et donc il
me donne des conseils en plus pour
cuisiner donc tout et tout est parfait
ici vous pouvez trouver l'introuvable et
le cuisiner comme par exemple des autos
c'est très saisonnier en gros c'est de
mars à avril répondent donc à ceux plus
pour le fun mais c'est un très beau 9
qui est pas très connu pour les produits
plus classiques comme les fraises ou les
salades les maraîchers doivent donner de
la voix pour se démarquer de la
concurrence
c'est dommage c'est un vin la ps3 pour 3
euros
ça vous fait le dernier à moitié prix il
faut pas remis en cause par les toujours
parler en fait tant qu'il n'a pas sorti
les billets faut envoyer après on obligé
de faire attention faut passer au
suivant
non plus importants déjà ce qu'ils
soient pas déçus pour qu'ils puissent
revenir
ben voilà il faut leur rappeler des tas
de trucs parce que et il oublie la
moitié des choses on mais lesquels
l'ambiance le cadre la qualité des
produits
autant d'atouts qui font que les
clunisiens tiennent à leur marché
quant aux prix puis sur notre actif oui
je trouve même des fois vous devriez
vendre plus cher ici on fait donc deux
bonnes affaires et l'on ne remplit pas
uniquement le garde-manger
les gens viennent au marché pour
l'alimentaire et grâce à ça il découvre
aussi que son de marché on peut aussi
trouver voilà des articles moi par
exemple tout ce qui est bijoux souvent
que des bijoux créatrice donc des trucs
voix qui sont pas fabriqués en chine
au fond des caves qui sont une partie
des bijoux jugement qui sont fabriqués
par une dame qui est à cluny et qui
fabrique que des pièces unis le marché
de cluny ne pourra que vous séduire tant
il est atypique et chaleureux